how much money would you say you made
over your career up until like you lost
it all I don't know the exact number but
I'd say over the years like with all the
spending she's like my monthly charges
on my AmEx were like 30 40 000 a month
on a low day on a low month
well over seven million I think so and
so you made over seven million and what
were you spending it all on I bought two
Ferraris about a Range Rover svr I
bought Rolexes my T4 my teeth cost a
hundred thousand dollars now grills
designer like I would go to Louie Gucci
Everything thinking that material
mentorship this is fake fake now but but
now material doesn't mean Jack to me I
understand like how in minuscule they
are cars and material things stupid it's
so stupid I I was trying to fill a void
thinking that buying more again an
addict more Was Gonna Fill the whole
more no it's not never gonna do that
[Music]